Hey, it's J.B. Smoove,
back on the set
of Curb Your Enthusiasm
for season ten.
Ooh ooh, we up in here, baby!
(LAUGHS) What's going on?
Uh, J.B., you're actually
not working today.
-So, so what's-- What?
-You're not working today.
-I'm not working today?
-Yeah.
The fuck I'm not!
Get the fuck outta here.
-I'm in, you good?
-MAN: Yeah.
What is there to love
about a poppy seed?
-Poppy seed's amazing.
-What, are you kidding?
What about sesame,
you like that, too?
I like saying it,
I don't like eating it.
-The only seed I can...
-Yeah. (CHUCKLES)
-What are you doing?
-Huh?
-What's going on?
We're filming!
-I'm filming, too!
-LARRY DAVID:
You're not in this scene.
-LARRY: You're not this scene.
-I'm in this shit now.
-You drove in full costume?
-J.B. SMOOVE: Fuck right I did!
-Right?
-Okay.
-You guys want preparation,
right?
-Okay, hey.
You're not in the scene.
Get out.
-I'm in this shit now.
I'm already here.
-No, you're not here.
-Get out. I don't care--
-I'm in the motherfucker, look.
Camera there, camera there.
-What is he doing?
-I'm in this shit already,
you hear?
-Okay, get the fuck out.
-Stop fucking up our scene.
Curb Your Enthusiasm,
season ten, up in this bitch!
♪ ("CURB YOUR ENTHUSIASM"
THEME MUSIC PLAYING) ♪